um as somebody who's uh
recently uh recently proposed to
somebody who
would like to spend the rest of my life
with as somebody who's married
and has uh from my knowledge uh
gone away for extensive periods of time
from their partner uh
what is your tips to building a uh
mortar-proof
marriage that's gonna last a long time
yep the first thing i'll say is
you know you want to develop the
you want your you want to make sure and
encourage
your wife to be emote
emotionally independent emotionally
independent
because there's gonna be times when
you're not around
and if they're dependent on you
emotionally
you're not there they're gonna they're
gonna be hurt
and they're not gonna be able to handle
it so you wanna help them
build that resiliency where
when you're not around they know how to
handle things
independently like the broken water
heater and the flat tire
they can do that and you you go through
those things you
you build that confidence with them and
then
also the emotional independence
where what they have is trust in you
that you're gone but you're coming back
and you're gonna be there for them
always
that's number one number two
is straight up
extreme ownership that's what it is
when something is going wrong in your
marriage it's your fault
it's your fault the minute you turn to
your wife and you say
you shouldn't have done this you're
wrong
and you're you're taking that
relationship in the wrong direction when
you say hey look i'm trying to figure
out
how i made you do what you did
i don't want to let that happen so
taking ownership when things go wrong
that's what you got to do
that's what you got to do thank you
awesome